it is 60 degrees here in Boston I did
vote today as you can see if you are
looking at my I voted sticker and it is
an incredibly different situation today
in this Democratic primary as it is
Super Tuesday than it was even 72 hours
ago and let's discuss let's look at
where we are let's look at what we
expect to happen so the DNC
establishment strategy in the last few
days ahead of today's Super Tuesday
primary is crystal clear get the hell
out of the race and endorse Joe Biden we
may never know although we may what
deals were struck and what negotiations
took place over the last three to four
days since Joe Biden easily won the
South Carolina primary but we have seen
Pete boot edge edge drop out and endorse
Joe Biden we saw Amy Klobuchar drop out
and endorse Joe Biden despite being
likely to get a bunch of Delegates in
tonight's Minnesota primary if she were
to stay in very quickly Joe Biden
gaining almost 20 points in Minnesota
thanks to the disappearance of Amy
Klobuchar as well as Pete Budaj edge
yesterday Joe Biden rallying in Texas
former presidential candidate beto or
Roarke known to most of us as Robert
O'Rourke also showing up to endorse Joe
Biden and this now is a strategy and if
you don't like it you've got a vote
because I'm gonna tell you from a
strategic perspective I was just talking
about this with a few different people
from a strategic perspective this
appears to be radically boosting Joe
Biden's chances today if you don't like
it don't attack the messenger get out
and vote Ken Joe Biden combined his
momentum from over-performing
in South Carolina with the endorsements
of multiple centrist candidates who have
pulled out and endorsed him can he turn
that into some victories outright
tonight and potentially deny Bernie
Sanders the nomination the betting money
believes that the answer is yes the
projections believe that the answer is
yes but people are still voting today
and I want to be as realistic as
possible about this it might work and it
might not and what it's going to come
down to is what happens in California
what happens in North Carolina what
happens later this month in some of the
later primaries this is now basically an
election between Biden and Bernie now
Elizabeth Warren and Michael Bloomberg
still have roles to play they just don't
have a shot at the nomination that's the
important thing to understand Elizabeth
Warren is still in the race in
Massachusetts it's not likely that she
wins but it is likely that she gets
delegates does she get out after tonight
does she wait until later in the race
what exactly is she trying to get out of
this I a month and a half ago would have
said Warren would be very likely to
endorse Bernie Sanders Bernie would be
very likely to choose Warren as a VP I
don't think either of those things is
true at this point in time and we will
see what Elizabeth Warren's future is
after tonight Michael Bloomberg is going
to get some delegates tonight in all
likelihood Michael Bloomberg also doing
well in the upcoming primary state of
Florida later on so is Bloomberg likely
to get out tonight or tomorrow I
actually don't think so
although there will be pressure on him
because again Bloomberg out would
further bolster Joe Biden and there's
been a debate going on within the left
about Bernie Sanders ceiling and it has
become so tired and rot to hear
corporate media Talking Heads say you
know Bernie's polling 15 in a seven or
eight Way race
20 might be his ceiling and then Bernie
pulls 20 and they say well Bernie's
polling 20 and what is effectively a 5
or 6 candidate race his ceiling is
probably 25 then Bernie pulls 25 and
they say he couldn't get more than 30 70
percent of the ill electorate will
always be against Bernie may not be true
because so far every single one of those
ceilings that has been pointed out by
someone on CNN or MSNBC has been broken
through that doesn't mean a ceiling
doesn't exist and it will be tested
today with the dropping out of Amy
Klobuchar and Pete Budaj and Michael
Bloomberg may indeed be a factor in a
number of tonight's contest so let's now
look at the big picture there are a
number of models in which Joe Biden
tonight could the word is good and it
depends on you going out and voting
Biden could come out of tonight with
more delegates than Bernie Sanders
however even if he does not it is
important to look at the path forward
and this is why it is imperative that if
Bernie Sanders wants to continue on his
path to the nomination he doesn't need
just some wins tonight he actually needs
some big wins and I'll tell you in which
states momentarily as you know Bernie
has been leading all sorts of states
including for example California heading
into today but again I'm being realistic
with you when Joe Biden won South
Carolina is that built momentum he then
gained some polling support and after
that Pete and Amy dropped out and now
there are people mark my words there are
people who were moving away from Biden
because he's been embarrassingly
implosive during the campaign who are
going back to Biden as they perceive him
to maybe have a shot at this thing so
the question is will it be enough and
there's only one group of people that
can determine that people like me who
went in voted today it's people like you
many of whom voted or will be voting the
538 primary forecast now has reversed
and has Joe Biden as the most likely
candidate to secure 50% plus one still
the most likely single scenario is no
one gets a majority of the delegates
before the convention that scenario
ranked as 60% likely to happen according
to 538 Joe Biden now 31% likelihood of
securing the nomination and Bernie
Sanders down to 8% now if you don't like
this then you just have to vote that's
the that's the path forward the models
I'm looking at basically have Bernie
Sanders coming out anywhere from a
hundred and twenty five or so delegates
ahead potentially all the way down to
tied my only prediction is if Bernie is
ahead tonight
by under 35 delegates I believe it
actually favors Biden because a lot of
those remaining states are southern
states in which Biden is likely to do
well as well as some northern states
like New York in which there will be a
roughly even split the key states I'm
looking at tonight
first of all California and California
Bernie's been surging for weeks and it
is a big prize 416 delegates if Bernie
wins California by 17 he's winning in
some polls by 17 that is a major
delegate advantage for Bernie tonight
Bernie wins California by 5 or 7 the way
the latest polls look it is not going to
be a big delegate margin for him and
that could eat away at the delegate lead
that Bernie needs coming out of tonight
the second state I'm looking at is North
Carolina North Carolina is much more
racially diverse than the early
primaries other than South Carolina and
Biden has been surging there recently
Biden's margin in North Carolina if he
does win is something that I would be
paying attention to and then lastly I
believe Minnesota is going to be an
interesting signal because Minnesota is
Amy Klobuchar home state according to
one poll done very recently from her
dropping out and endorsing Biden Biden
has gone from eight in Minnesota to 27
in Minnesota
almost tying Bernie Sanders if Minnesota
is something like Bernie 32 and Biden 27
the way one poll has it right now that
is going to show that the DNC strategy
worked
if this sounds bad to you if this
doesn't sound like what you want to see
happen there's one thing you can do
which is go and vote and like right now
especially if polls are about to close
in your state and number to get other
people to go out and vote we'll have
live stream results tonight don't miss
it youtube facebook as well as twitch
look forward to seeing you there I've
been posting videos to this cool new
platform rizal the videos can be up to
60 seconds long I often use it to ask
the audience questions people respond
with their own
messages and then I respond to them it's
very very cool after posting 30 videos
of your own you can get sponsored by the
community and make money new creators
are able to have their videos seen by
many many people and the platform just
works really well on mobile every week
Rizal also hosts fun video competitions
where you can win money
check it out follow me on Rizal use the
link down in the video description